okay hello everybody I am here with
Thomas went on to van result and we are
going to talk to you about the New
Avengers endgame movie we did a video
about it about infinity war just a few
weeks ago talking especially about human
sacrifice and the story of human
sacrifice and we were both really
excited to see how the new movie
resolves all those questions that we
were posing and so we're going to be
talking about it to get
[Music]
this is Jonathan pezzo welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
so hey Thomas maybe you can start off
you're usually so good at giving us a
little small like a very synthetic
vision of the plot and then we can you
can jump into the symbolism okay so I
guess for those who haven't watched
infinity war is there a major spoiler so
if you yet if you don't want spoilers
for sure we don't even think about that
yeah I mean if you if you made it this
far five spoilers then then you don't
want to be spoiled here at this point
but so an infinity war it's basically
the culmination of the 21 Marvel movies
that came before and it's about all the
Marvel superheroes facing off against
the supervillain Thanos and Thanos wants
to gather all these these powerful
Infinity stones to kill off half of the
universe because he thinks by killing
off half of the universe he will save it
because he thinks overpopulation will be
a problem and it has been a problem on
his own planet so that's his aim so his
aim is not it's not in his own eyes bad
but he thinks he will be a sort of God
Savior of source and so an infinity war
he actually succeeds in doing so and
it's because of the hero's inability to
to fight him in inappropriate way in an
appropriate way so what they do is
instead of self sacrificing themselves
they try to save in the individuals
sorry to try to save the the individual
in in favor of the collective am I
saying that right yeah would to play on
both a day that you have some who are
willing to save the individual - to save
one individual like their the person
they love in order to try to save them
and sacrifice a collective
yes sorry yeah and also do the opposite
and you have others who are willing to
do the opposite which is to sacrifice
one person in order to save the totality
say sacrifice someone else and so it's
all about this this this problem of
human sacrifice and so in end games so
Fenelon says one and half of the
universe's now that and the world has
descended into a sort of nihilism
pessimism and depression
the remaining heroes now go out and
actually kill thanos they find him and
kill him but but they can bring half the
universe back because he has already
destroyed the very stones that they need
to to turn back time and to to bring
everyone back and so now their aim is to
somehow find a way to turn back time and
bring everyone back and they do it by
inventing time travel and and trying to
get all these stones together and and
snap the world back into into existence
so to say so that's basically the entire
plot but most of it is all about
resolving all these character arcs and
and culminating this the in the final
moment of these and ten last years of
the MCU so I think that I think that in
this case really the time travel which
is usually such a mess in terms of sorry
you know I can because I'm at terms of
story tellings and maybe it is a mess
but it ended up ends up being a great
way to revisit all their plot lines and
kind of tie everything together so you
have to close your eyes in terms of the
let's say the all the plot holes that
are there I mean there's so many plot
holes in the story and they they have
these little leaves these little
explanation moments where they're trying
to explain to you why there's a plot
hole and how they're how they don't like
why is it that they can't go back again
and save them again you're like that's
always the problem with time travel but
anyways if that doesn't matter because
you're so taken up by how they're able
to pull all the threads together and I
have to give them to really take my head
off to them because it's most of one of
the most satisfying movies I've watched
in a while in terms of doing that where
you think how is it that they were able
to bring all these every character has
their moment every storyline find some
kind of resolution everything that's
left that has been left out you know
you know Tony Stark's relationship with
his father you know that Captain
America's relationship with that woman
that the agent the agent that he he left
behind all of that everything kind of
comes together and every everyone finds
their own little resolution so first of
all I have to say then it was they
deserve their whatever 2 billion dollars
that they got for this oh yeah yeah
bringing it all together yeah I have to
say I went the very the premiere night
and
I'm not really an MCU Fennessy I follow
the movies off and on but I did decide
to to rewatch and watch all the ones
that I hadn't watched previously just in
preparation and I was like of course the
entire room was packed and but I've
never been in such an experience of like
cinematic experience where everyone was
so involved in a movie that it was it
was very much a visceral experience that
you wouldn't get if you watched his
movie on TV so no I would just see it in
I want to see the IMAX and I had my
daughter with me who is and she she when
we told her when you're 10 you can start
watching kind of Star Wars Marvel level
movies okay and so in the last six
months she's like I want to see endgame
because she wanted to see endgame we had
to watch all the necessary we didn't
watch all twenty but like the necessary
movies let's say to get it right though
she was all in it like so weary watch
all the whoo and she was all in it and
I've never seen her like that she was
jumping in her seat she was she was
exclaiming out at the screen she saw
spider-man appears she was like I was
like I'm like with a little fangirl you
know so I was I was able to live my joy
kind of through her and yeah there's a
little moment so I kind of had a little
I had a little bit of a tear little bit
of tear moments you know partly also
because of her how excited she was and
just everything was happening so exactly
admit that I was totally taken up by the
ya know I had the same experience but
that must have been if it's your own
daughter that must have been on another
level yeah sure I must have been good so
yeah anyways so let's go on CD to the
analysis so I was really happy - as well
- that we did that video that we wanted
to do because you know we've been
thinking about doing the endgame video
and know everything was there was a lot
of things going on and so we finally did
it before we dating the infinity war
video and then we did it before and game
came out and I felt like we really
nailed the right nails in like we really
had gotten to the core of what the story
was about and right watching endgame
confirmed that because they seem to deal
with that very problem that we had in
terms of the storyline and how it was
reintroducing this weird you know
individual versus collective and we said
even at the end that let's say the thing
the Christian answer to that problem has
been self-sacrifice but that has been
like the kind of Christian answer and
then that becomes a major theme of of
endgame as well right yeah I think and
it's exactly like that it's if if
infinity war was was battles this movie
which they claim it is as well it's all
about Thanos and it's all about his
philosophy of the necessity of coercing
or sacrificing other people for the
greater good so to say and it's all and
it's actually sort of confirming that
philosophy to be true he wins in the end
and and the Avengers are unable to do
what they must do to prevent it from
happening and so if that is the case in
endgame it is then again flipped on its
on his head or flip back on his feet
router it's and and it becomes instead
of this coercing or sacrificing other
sort of greater good it is it becomes
the voluntary self-sacrifice for that
higher good and and and and then yeah
that's I think it's it fits really
nicely instant when I was first watching
endgame I noticed it very very early on
even from the moment that so any stark
when he still has his family his family
miraculously did not get snapped and so
he's the only one and so he his life is
actually pretty good but then when I
noticed that he actually decides then to
to let that go or potentially let that
go I was like oh I know where it is
headed and I already that moment I knew
okay he's not going to he's not going to
make it yeah yeah but it didn't matter
because it was it was very powerful I
was like I was happy that I was gonna go
in that directions yeah and I think
especially it was powerful about using
Tony Stark as you know the main thread
in terms of self-sacrifice one of course
is that he's the best actor I mean he's
obviously the most charismatic of all
and you know they keep putting him in
other movies because he was so he's like
oh we'll just put well just put Tony
Stark in the in the spider-man movie
just in case make sure that it that it
work whatever in the the Captain America
movies you know to make sure that that
they do well so for sure there was that
but also because he was his whole
character was about a kind of
narcissistic person in the beginning who
who you know who's a woman
who just thinks about himself and and
then you just see this major arc of
himself coming to the end where he
actually becomes less narcissistic
because he's able to have a wife and a
child but then he has to take that even
further which is the capacity to even
sacrifice that in terms in order to to
fully kind of empty himself you know to
to save everyone and so that made the
whole arc so powerful you know even more
than just having someone sacrifice
themselves is because you know
everything he's been through you got to
know his story and and how he who he was
and he plays it convincingly - you
really do feel that he's able to even
keep even in his self-sacrifice he keeps
a bit of his snark a bit of his attitude
all the way to the end but he's doing it
in a kind of flips it into this this
moment where he gives himself so that
was really well played for sure yeah and
I think what I noticed as well as that
they played his his sort of final
Arcanist movie as as a sort of Return of
the King journey as you know he starts
off in like floating in space like far
away far away and chaos and and he's
slowly dying you know he's going into
death and then he also he's saved but
then he still loses his identity as Iron
Man he rejects that identity he takes
out his heart you can happen then and
then you know the world goes on they
kill Thanos but they can't do anything
about what has happened and so when they
find Tony again he is not involved
anymore with with the Avengers
initiative you know like there's only a
couple people in the building left and
he's living out somewhere out in the
woods and and living his own life of his
family and so then it's all about you
know he has to then reaiiy denta phi
himself with with that that identity of
iron man and and then was what you say
it has to take that that spirit of
self-sacrifice i guess to to the next
level in a sense that okay first he
accepts that he needs to try and figure
out how time travel works and then he
needs to accept that he might have to
let go of his family in in favor of
trying to save you know I think the
inciting moment is that he sees that
picture of Peter Parker and he has
responsibility to at least try and bring
him back because he's been this fatherly
figure towards him and then finally it's
also he goes back in time and he finds
some sort of I think it's some sort of
closure in his relationship with his
with his father but I don't I don't I'm
not quite sure what his relationship
previously washed because I'm not I'm
not that I don't believe I'm not that
knowledgeable about about the whole MCU
history but I think I don't there was
something unresolved there I feel like
but and then he says something to him
but I forgot the quote but that takes
him to to you know to find a moment when
he comes back into the present time and
he finally needs to face off against
against Thanos and that's the moment
when he's able to to renew the world but
he's an in his self-sacrifice so I
thought that's they played that whole
story like perfectly and it's I think
for maximum maximum effect yeah sure the
other way no it was it was and
everything was played so well because
there is this idea in you know we had
this idea in Christianity that Christ
trampled down death by death like this
idea that he tricked death by dying
right so this notion that when Christ
was crucified everybody the devil
thought that he had one right because
here I crucified God I killed God did I
ki one but then by bringing Christ down
into death then that it's like bringing
light into darkness it flipped it all
around and so they played that part
really well which is Toni first of all
tricks
Thanos you know with the glove thing
where it's a nose thinks that all of a
sudden he has the glove but then no like
the he's able he took the stones and
there's this like final trick at the end
where he gets the stones back and then
he he basically uses the power Thanos
used to destroy half the universe he
then uses that against Thanos and
against his army and against all those
people though then they they all
disappear and everything is restoring it
so there's this this great kind of this
this I would talk about this double
inversion right so it's like yeah yeah
the Thanos kind of flipped things and
then using the same narrative structure
you know then they flip it back so that
everything returns to to to to what it
should be so you don't have right so all
of that was played definitely very well
and the scene the scene I think one of
the the best scenes or the best played
scenes where was this
with Hawkeye and what is her name
vinegar the black black widow because
because we had that scene in infinity
war with Gomorrah where you have the
human sacrifice and now they played the
same scene but now you have these two
characters who are fighting about who's
going to sacrifice themselves which was
which I thought everything was just so
well played and that's in that sense
right that it's it's a it's like a
subversion it's all in version as well
where it's like it's not they're
fighting over who has to kill well it's
not like oh you have to die or you have
to die it's more like I have to die and
or and the other person's like no I have
to died so it's yeah that's I think that
was very clear that mystic order they're
flipping the the story one 180 from
infinity war this is also like a secret
admission of how much they care for each
other because the idea was you have to
kill the thing you care most about like
you have to sacrifice the the thing you
care most about and so here you have
this admission that especially Hawkeye
losing his family
now here's black widow they're the two
people that care the most about each
other and so so the so you kinda a
testimony to their strength to their
relationship and then at the same time
now fighting over who's gonna have to
sacrifice ya know yeah it's so simple
it's such a simple arithmetic but it it
ends up being so powerful when you see
it you know play itself out mm-hmm and
and it mean like annecy self-sacrifice
play themselves out even in smaller ways
as well and you know you have with
almost all of the character so like most
of them like nebula who has to fight
herself as well and ultimately kill
herself in order to save the person she
initially hated so it's like a final
final moment where we see that that she
is now she's now no longer this this
villain or does bad person she's now
truly like an Avenger I guess or I think
that was that was one of the smartest
ways that they played self-sacrifice in
the whole story because there are so
many characters who do that Captain
America ends up having to find himself
and kind of heating himself down in
order to to to to take the the Infinity
stone and then Tony Stark does the same
he actually causes his old self to have
a heart attack in order it's always like
in
of everything ends up being turned back
on a fight with yourself like fight with
yourself for killing your old self or
you know being willing to watch yourself
suffer all of that happens in small ways
but you know all building up towards
this kind of these these two big
sacrifices at the end so I mean it was
it was played in in the mind you in the
smallest detail this played really well
yeah and I think because you have all
these the it works and all these levels
it is also the entire film becomes a
rejection of the philosophy of Thanos
and indifferent or most of it at least
we can argue a little bit about it but
it becomes sort of a rejection of the in
the first film in the sense that you
know the first film is about Thanos
saying that well once I have snapped
half the universe out of existence
people will be grateful and and and it
will be sort of a rebirth but then it is
shown that it's not exactly it's not
that but it's more like a slow
descendant to death I people become
nihilistic Clint or Hawkeye you know he
he's fuel on his hatred and he just
tries to kill all the bad people burn so
he goes like really crazy and and so
because Thanos also sees that that
people weren't grateful now his
philosophies taken to its extreme in a
sense that now he wants to kill everyone
and exists and just start and I think
one of the greatest parts of the movie
was exactly that how because in the
first movie if you're if you're
objective you're watching the story you
know you there's something a little
convincing about Thanos yeah because he
gives us examples he says my world this
happened in my world
he is example of a gamora's world where
it succeeded and Sokka if you're if
you're if you're objective and you're
kind of listening and you're watching
him you're seeing that he's willing to
go to the end of his ideas like he's
willing to kind of take it to the end
and so there was something strangely
convincing about Thanos and in the kind
of good bad guy like the way a good good
bad guy should be now in this movie he's
actually totally exposed as being the
narcissist that he is because he first
of all he's willing like you said to now
he's like I'm gonna destroy everything
and remake everything in my image
basically is what he's saying right he's
like I'm
the whole world in a way that they'll be
grateful to me he says at least now
they'll be grateful to me and he exposes
himself there and then there's another
scene where he's in danger and he calls
for the cannons to like shoot down on
the the fighters and his own generals or
whatever say well yeah but our our army
you're gonna destroy harm and he's like
I don't care just do it you know because
I'm important it's me and it actually
ends up exposing his real nature let's
say and then you don't he's not
convincing at all like he doesn't he
totally he loses his sheen of seduction
you could say supply which is what well
yeah and then I think and then it's it's
also his line where he says I am
inevitable and he's like a sort of
ultimate determinist in the sense that
he think that like this is inevitably
going to happen and like we have to like
killing half of the people like I guess
all the people is that's that's ultimate
goal like that's the ultimate end but
then it is refuted by Tony Stark saying
like I am Iron Man and and so I think it
also plays into this idea of technology
and in a sense that the technology the
boundless technology that they have was
that the cause of the genocide of half
the planet of the planet and maybe
that's also why Donna says he's
inevitable that this is inevitably going
to happen but then it is also technology
is the solution that that that can
prevent it from happening but not
technology in itself but it's more I
felt like it was more the spirit of
self-sacrifice that was guiding it that
that it could also be something that
would redeem the universe and yet
they've been time-travel and they they
use the technology to you know to renew
the world right so I thought they give a
sort of full view of the power and the
destructiveness of technology that they
but they have because you know daughter
movies are all about the the danger of
the Avengers as well because they're so
powerful you know in civil war it's all
about well you know all this collateral
damage and are you doing more good than
you were doing harm and so I think those
two themes also played into infinity war
and
and endgame as well so that that that
was nicely done yeah I agree I agree the
idea of power itself like the problem of
power you know and the problem yeah kind
of like I talked about in my video on
the Lord of the Rings and the ring this
the problem of power itself and how it
has two sides like it you know it has
it's always it's always it's always kind
of increases you but it also is
dangerous and it also makes you
vulnerable to the very power that you
yeah increasing you like it makes you it
puts you in danger yeah for sure that
was definitely played out well um and so
then when one of the interesting things
that I thought was the crossing arcs of
Tony Stark and Captain America that
those two I found I thought they did
that very well as also because cap you
know Captain America was at the right at
the beginning this he becomes Captain
America because he's so selfless that's
why they choose him right because in the
first movie he throws himself on a
grenade and I think the grenades not an
actual grenade but they see that he's
willing to just sacrifice himself for
everybody else and so because of that
they choose him to become Captain
America and then he becomes this image
like this symbol of patriotism of of
self-sacrifice willing to sacrifice
yourself for others he become that
becomes his image and then you have on
the opposite side you have Iron Man Tony
Stark who is a narcissist who selfish
was all of that and so then you have
these two crossing arcs where it's as if
Captain America has to learn to also be
more than just an ideal like he has to
learn to be a human being and enter into
relationships and have a family
basically and so then he actually in the
end he actually gets the nice little
life and he's he that's part of his arc
right all right the opposite way where
he has to become Captain America in the
end and sacrifice himself so I thought I
mean I just so you think like did they
think about this right from the
beginning like this whole how they're
gonna cross it you know and then have a
have a conflict between them in the
middle and then finally they kind of
come back together in the end but but
each one has learned from the other
something like that like my goodness
that's some storytelling yeah it was I
hadn't you told me just now and I hadn't
thought of it that way I was like well
what
actually really really well done yeah
yeah even even hulk-like actually
resolves himself you know by integrating
his dad oh it's a union would say you
know can integrates his dark side and so
then he he becomes just this monster
who's kind of like a huge Solaris that
character was a layered image was yeah
yeah no and and he had his moment of
self-sacrifice as well when he is like
well this is my duty to to put on this
the glove and and tried to bring
everyone back even though they know that
that it might it might kill him
yeah Sharad so every almost all the
major liquor characters did have a
moment like that in this movie right so
the problem the problem of the figuring
out is Thor like this the for character
is a little more complicated to kind of
figure out you know where they're going
where they were trying to do for sure it
was hilarious I mean it was so that that
his whole heart was arc was so funny
because you know especially because Thor
at the beginning in the first movies he
was so high and mighty and playing he
would speak almost in Elizabethan
English you know he had a slightly
English accent and now you come to the
end where he's he's a gamer he's sitting
on his couch drinking beer you know and
he's basically kinda lost his purpose in
life so it was funny but what do you
think in terms of the meaning like how
do you how do you see it we I don't know
if it were gonna get it to a solution
but we were we were talking about that
even before the video so yeah so I think
we need to take into account that what
happened in Thor Ragnarok I don't know
if you've watched that movie is really
crazy as well I thought it was really
funny but I think it worked really well
into making this this sort of rogue hero
character into ultimately the king of
his people and sort of in his own way
but it's like it he had a long long
journey to get there and he lost a scart
and and everything happened but then
right after that infinity war happens
and he loses again anyways so it makes
sense that he would go and and and and
into does to prep the press of state and
becomes as this low full person and he's
fat and everything and he's anxious and
so he becomes like the opposite of what
he was before almost and but then the
thing is
he throughout the movie he stays and as
he becomes more for comic relief
character and I think a lot of people
who like Thor didn't quite enjoy because
they wanted him to to become four again
and so in the end he does you know he
sort of has a redemptive moment and he
finally you know restores himself SSS
being for but the thing is I think that
the crux like the question is his arc is
all focused on him going back to to
resolve the death of his mom which he
wasn't able to prevent in the second
Thor movie and so he talks to her and I
think he just wants to be with her wants
to save her but she tells him look
notice this has already happened and you
can't really do anything about it and
then she tells them you need to be who
you are and not who you are supposed to
be and that then becomes sort of his his
mantra throughout the rest of the movie
and in the end what he does is instead
of retaking his place as the king of new
Asgard he now decides that you know I'm
going to be Who I am and not who am I
supposed to be I'm not going to be the
king I'm gonna be four and I'm gonna
hang out with the our galaxy and go on
adventures so even though this is this
is exciting because those two the least
you have these two groups have have good
chemistry of each other and like I'm
sure that last scene was hilarious in
the in the space absolutely so you can
tell us like oh what is this going to be
good but then you also have this you can
interpret it in a way where as he is now
rescinding his responsibilities to
someone else and he's degenerating back
into a more immature state as a sort of
adolescent hero type character sort of
Peter Pan you know always going on
adventures and so especially if you are
like oh you have to be who you are and
not who you're supposed to be can also
be interpreted as that you're like sort
of static you can change who you are you
should just a self accept whatever
whatever it may be like you can it can
become sort of a way of not improving
yourself like that we can see but then
there's also the other side where it's
like four is has always had this high
image of himself he's a bit of a
narcissist in a way and so when once he
was unable to defeat Thanos he actually
instead of going for it ahead infinity
war he tries to drag it out like he he
hits
in the chest and so that's ultimately
his own ego that that the feet that
kills half of the universe and so then
his ego is completely destroyed so it
also makes sense that he maybe had his
persona was was this vision of himself
as too inflated and so you can interpret
it as that and maybe so in the Guardians
movie the next gardius movie will see it
more I guess a more natural progression
to to to something something greater I
guess for sure one of the smart things
that the way in terms of the character
one of the intelligence things they did
is they had him cut
thanassis head off which was so smart
because Sano tells him in the in in
infinity war he says you should have you
should have gone for the head or
something like that like you should have
cut my head off and so now Thor as soon
as he sees them you know he starts his
bad guy speech and cuts his head off but
cutting his head off ends up being as
much an admission of his own failure as
it is of success at that moment where he
he actually kills him then when he later
he says something like I'm the one who
killed him did you kill him did who what
which one of you killed Thanos he's
actually he's actually admitting his own
failure from the from from infinity was
really really smart really played well
in that sense and so maybe maybe the
best case scenario for Thor is that he
has abandoned his pretense right he's
abandoned he stopped thinking that he's
better than what he is you know and so
he's got a dark moment to go through in
order to become something more and and
in the end of the movie they actually
make you feel like okay his art is not
over it's just starting and we'll see
him in the next guardians of the galaxy
movie or something like that and
hopefully he'll he'll you know at least
lose the weight or something you know
and and fine it's yeah I hope that will
happen like I'm like that's I think the
only movie that I'm really excited for
just because I like the character and I
like what they did with Ragnarok and I
so and I like the Guardians as well so I
think that will mash well together so
I'm hopeful as well but I do understand
the criticism from people who have
watched Ragnarok and who like Thor is
that because in wreck rocky goes through
like a pretty dark phase as well as dad
dies and he could continuously it's like
it's basically saying like how can I be
the
the king or like how I'm the god of
thunder but hehe you can't accept that
like he doesn't know that he has that
power and then he doesn't need the
hammer - to be - to have that identity I
guess and so it's very good
go ahead go ahead I was gonna say one of
the positive things in the movie in
terms of showing that maybe that's where
he's going is that you know their scene
I forget it's I think it's in the second
Avengers movie where Thor kind of puts
his hammer on the table and then
everybody tries to lift it and he's kind
of like hahaha you suckers like I'm the
god of thunder you know you're all a
bunch of loser mortals and you there's
no way you can do anything and then in
this movie when Captain America picks up
the hammer and uses it
Thor actually rejoices he's actually
joyful to see someone else be worthy of
the hammer whereas in the in in another
movie in the earlier movies he probably
would have felt like okay this is a jab
me to knock at me that that uh that
someone else can use the hammer yeah and
I think that's also the reason why
Captain America and the Avengers Ultron
I think that he knew that he could pick
it up but then he didn't because he knew
also knew that that would hurt thoris
ego and that would like interesting
that's an interesting idea because he
does in Ultron he moves it right it kind
of helps a little bit
you see Thor become nervous that's true
I forgot that yeah oh yes so as I heard
people saying that that he probably
could have picked it up but then he just
because he is Captain America and and
you know he's selfless he is he's like I
have to not do this because it's not
gonna be good for for for a Thor at this
moment so I write and that you read
about I hadn't thought about him
rejoicing over over picking up the
hammer yes I mean that's great that's
great storytelling there for sure yeah
for sure
alright so now we need to get to that we
need to get to the the more difficult
part the more difficult problem which is
one of the things that I have been
suggesting in the past few years is
there seems to be a narrative in these
action types movies where in the trope
of self-sacrifice there seems to be a
strange idea that we need to sacrifice
ourselves
but then in order to give power to
someone who has some marginalized
identity you know either
this idea of being replaced by a woman
or being replaced by some other
character that is it somehow
marginalized and so the question is the
difficulty in this movies that you see
some of that for sure in some of some of
the the scenes and sadly there is that
one scene the kind of female superhero
power moment in the movie where all
these women superheroes kind of come
together in this really choreographed
shot and then they're like all fighting
together it's a very strange moment
because a lot of the characters are good
characters and you know they probably
could have you know interesting arts and
everything but it was so choreographed
that it just did not I know I just stood
out to me as being this very strange
fake moment and very deliberate moment
and so then it's hard then then you then
that's like the cue it's like it's hard
not for it not to be the cue to think
okay okay so this is part of their
thinking this is what this one of the
things they want and so when then Thor
gives his power over to this very
marginal character Valkyrie which we
just met once in the in Ragnarok movie
who's basically a she's a she's a
warrior and no so he gives his power to
her and tells her he'll be better at it
than I am and all this it's like okay
this is very strange like this is very
weird and then there's again the the
Captain America who gives his shield to
Falcon which is it's like it's hard to
understand because what I don't
understand how can fall can be Captain
America he doesn't have any power like
just terms of the story so you know it
doesn't make sense just because he has a
shield like how is he going to like if
you gave me Captain America's shield
like what am I gonna do with it I can't
throw it and bounce it off the walls
like Captain America doesn't like it
doesn't make any sense and so then it's
hard not to see it as being justified by
some weird political desire to to play
to this kind of social justice stuff so
yeah I mean to me it seemed it might
have might be sort of a precursor for
what's to come in the next phase of
Marvel movies I dunno will left wait and
see I guess but for sure that especially
that moment where it's the all sort of
female power moment it was the only
really the only scene it felt very
jarring even if you if you don't care
about the politics surrounding it I
think even if you just look at a story
level it felt very artificial to the
story like it that that just to be
completely out of the immersion for a
couple seconds but I know you like
obviously it is some some type that was
some type of more like a virtue whose
signal I would say because I have a
friend of mine who would agree with
these types of this type of imagery in
movies and he was silent for the entire
movie but that when Decca came on he's
like ooh I love that then at this so for
sure they were pandering to a certain
audience with that with that moment
wasn't just like for the story like that
I think that is naive to do you say
sorry going keep keep talking keep
talking no I was I was we were gonna
keep saying that I interrupt you and and
I probably do which is horrible
so best-case scenario space scenario for
that is that they I think the
unapologetically played out the main
characters from Avengers you know and so
because a lot of the main characters
were men in the in the original stories
I think they they said we're gonna
unapologetically play out those
characters play you know have Tony Stark
be the hero have Captain America
everybody gonna have their moment
everybody's gonna have their their
intense moment in the story and so of
course of all those characters Black
Widow was the only original and she does
have her amazing moment in the story but
and it ends up being mostly guys and so
I think it was like okay we're gonna
unapologetically do that but then we
need to give this little this little you
know this little thing where at least
we're showing people that were on their
side that we're were woke that you know
like you said it's it was a kind of
virtue signal so that no one was too
annoyed that Tony Stark ends up being
the one who saves the day in the end you
know yeah hopefully that's the best
that's the best case scenario for that
and the worst case scenario is like you
said it's that they're showing us the
future you know and that Captain Marvel
is the future and all and that they're
going to play into that
they're gonna play the politics more
which would be too bad for marble in
terms of yeah yeah so I guess the future
will we'll decide on how we can
interpret what happened and an endgame
here the futures female so but one of
the things I had to give them though is
that I think they really played fans
really well and they played the whole
because some people were so scared that
Captain Marvel was gonna come in and
just kill Thanos and she would be a DSP
not right and they actually played with
that they played with our expectations
because they give us that moment where
she kind of comes in you know and she's
like she destroys the spaceship and
she's just like coming anything oh my
goodness this is not this is not gonna
be good cuz like who is this character
she comes in and she starts and so you
think it might go that way and it
finally he just throws her to the side
and so and so I thought they really that
was a really smart way to kind of show
her power but at the same time give us
the story from you but got like resolve
the story from the last 20 movies like
don't give us this one character that
appears that solved the storyline it
would have been would have been dramatic
if they had done it that way absolutely
absolutely yeah it would have been it
would have been the equivalent of what
happened and Game of Thrones I know you
don't watch I don't watch Game is that
what happened Game of Thrones well
something like that happens not as I
wouldn't say it's not as bad as as if
Captain Marvel would if the feet of
Thanos but it's it's actually pretty
similar in terms of storytelling we had
that in the Star Wars movie we had that
blue haired Admiral who sacrifices
herself and saves the day
she's the hero of the story but we've
never seen her before she just appears
in this movie for like 20 minutes and
that's a sudden like she's the one who
takes the she basically saves the day
like they did that for sure I'm hoping I
think Marvel definitely learned from
Star Wars and we wish his Star Wars
we've learned from Marvel a little bit
at this point yeah late for them yeah
farts farts awake well yeah I don't
think I might not even go I might even
go see it I didn't go see solo I
probably will not probably won't see it
just wait for it to come out and yeah
yeah I don't know or something
yeah but at least we had our little our
little endgame moment which was
definitely worth it we'll see where it
goes we hopefully it'll it won't play to
the worst aspects of our the more
political aspects that we saw in the
movie and that they'll keep giving us
good character arcs and good characters
and you know we always say like I don't
mind there being great you know female
characters that's awesome like if we can
do it but give us good stories I don't
give us just politically veneered just
like political stories with with a
superhero veneer on it that does it it's
not gonna find a fly but Captain Marvel
made a lot of money though so that's a
bit it's a bit worrisome yeah I didn't I
didn't watch the movie so I know alright
so there anything else that you want to
say on to end our discussion about about
this let's see I don't I don't think so
I think I've said about every thing that
I did I written down so yeah I don't
know if you have anything no I think no
I think we recovered it and I think I'm
still happy that we we got to called it
you know just before the movie came out
and so they hit the nail on the head
like just precisely so it was a it was a
it was good
alright time so as usual thanks for your
discussion and everybody don't forget to
check out the storytellers channel and
in Thomas's great movie interpretations
there as well and we'll see you soon if
you enjoyed this content and our
exploration of symbolism get involved I
love to read your insights and questions
in the comments section you can also
share this video on social media to your
friends as you can please consider
supporting us financially through
patreon or PayPal you'll find those
links in the description below
[Music]